c'est qu'au maire de londres que les
britanniques ont appris à le connaître
je veux leur en mêlée et black
maladroite il a vu vallée charmer avec
son c est cousu et brouillon avant
son souci politique boris johnson était
journaliste surtout connu pour le ton
acerbe de ses chroniques dans le daily
telegraph
johnson qui se moque allègrement des et
les déconnecter de londres est lui même
issu de la bourgeoisie anglaise il
fréquente les grandes écoles et étudie à
oxford aux côtés de ceux qui ne
viendront plus tard six collègues au
parlement i would like you
know c'est grâce au président que la
carrière politique de johnson prend une
envergure nationale rapidement il se
positionne comme une figure de proue du
camp lives favorable au retrait de
l'union européenne riche et
beau frère en 2016 il devient ministre
des affaires étrangères dans le
gouvernement de theresa may
johnson démissionne deux ans plus tard
pour signaler son désaccord à 92 chef de
mais incapable dit-il de livrer le
breakbeat
l'année suivante johnson est couronné
comme nouveau chef du parti conservateur
il déclenche ensuite des élections
générales avec un message clair express
un slogan efficace qui permet autorise
d'obtenir leur meilleur résultat
électoral depuis les années 80 comme les
sections
eco prensa
fred est au
mieux avec une super majorité au
parlement johnson entérine finalement le
brésil n'est les célébrations seront
courtes quelques mois plus tard c'est le
début de la pandémie tout au long de la
crise sanitaire le gouvernement johnson
multiplie les ratés et le premier
ministre chute dans les sondages et le
succès de la campagne de vaccination et
la levée des restrictions sanitaires lui
refont gagner la confiance du public
johnson et téflon il semble survivre à
tous les scandales et aucune gaffe ne
lui colle même celle sur sa vie
personnelle tumultueuse du moins c'était
avant la plus récente cascade de
controverses qui aura finalement eu
raison de la mûre de boris johnson la
fin on a été abrupte et peu cérémonieuse
pour un homme qui rêvait pourtant d'être
le tshirt celle du xxième siècle ici at
média radio canada toronto